it's great to be joined today by dr.
Joseph saccharin who is number one a
former victim of gun violence also a
clinician and researcher at Johns
Hopkins Hospital and founder of the
hashtag this is our lane social media
movement with the goal of reducing
firearm death and disability in America
dr. saccharin great to talk to you first
of all yeah thanks so much for having me
David so let's talk first about how the
sort of controversy started involving
doctors who work on treating and
reducing gun violence in the United
States and the NRA the hashtag this is
our lane if people haven't been
following this controversy what's it all
about yeah so the night before Thousand
Oaks
mass shooting November 7th I believe the
NRA sent out a communication and a
message that essentially implied that
the medical community should stay in
their Lane when it comes to providing
solutions around gun violence in America
and in fact not only did they say that
but they also said that we had pretty
much not consulted anyone else and so
you know those you know types of
rhetoric and communication is what
really started this movement and United
healthcare professionals all across this
country your particular background is
relevant here because you were the
victim of gun violence basically by
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time can you talk about that a little
bit yeah so at the age of 17 I was
nearly killed after being shot in the
throat and you know David at that point
in my life I really had no idea what I
wanted to do in the future you know
you're young you don't realize the fact
that you're mortal but I was inspired I
was really
inspired to take that second chance that
I was given and really provide other
people with the same types of
opportunities and so and that's what
drove me into medicine that's what drove
me to becoming a trauma surgeon and then
really you know for many years I've been
working at that intersection of medicine
public health and public policy to try
to make communities safe for all across
America we've seen attempts in politics
in general to sort of try to discredit
groups with certain characteristics as
being legitimate sort of authorities or
legitimately enabled to comment on
particular issues so like without having
any idea what your politics are some
some ideas that that I present on my
show include you know on on climate
science we've seen the so called climate
skeptic movement try to say well a lot
of those scientists don't practice the
exact right type of science that they
would really know about climate change
or we saw during the LGBTQ rights debate
some who opposed LGBT rights say well if
you're part of the LGBT community you
shouldn't have a say because you're
biased of course ignoring that not being
in a group provides the same type of
bias that being in a group just from a
different perspective so can you talk a
little bit here about why folks in your
position and the medical profession
actually are in a position to talk about
gun violence in the United States yeah
well I think it's a really important
question and in fact there's there's a
couple really I think critical pieces in
your question the first is what is going
on in this country surrounding gun
violence is really an attempt to
polarize a topic it's an attempt to
continue this false narrative that as
Americans we are so divided when it
comes to this issue and I think David
when you look at the leadership of the
gun lobby and the membership there
a significant disparity that exists yes
and in fact I've talked to hundreds if
not thousands of gun owners and guess
what we pretty much agree on most of the
aspects and solutions that need to be
taken in order to move the needle
forward on this the second part of your
question I think relates to us as
clinicians and I'll just say this you
know we are front and center of taking
care of these patients day in and day
out and so for a group or an individual
to think that health care professionals
are not part of the solution I think
shows a real lack of understanding of
how complex this problem is and the
reality is is that there is no one
individual or one organization that's
going to solve this problem this is
going to require stakeholders from
diverse backgrounds and views you know
including healthcare gun owners policy
makers and so forth one of the positions
that we heard from individuals
associated with the NRA if not the NRA
itself is that doctors should just treat
people and basically otherwise shut up
but even without having to address that
in this particular case like as a
general rule isn't it very common that
doctors work both in treatment but also
research and prevention absolutely I
mean first of all you know this is farm
injury and death in this country is a
public health crisis and you know part
of our role is to treat this not just
when they come into our trauma centers
but before they ever get shot the injury
prevention piece that you talk about and
so that is something when you look at
other public health problems we have
dealt with time and time again for
example motor vehicle fatalities you
know in the 60s and 70s we were having
high fatality --zz we didn't get rid of
cars
you know we made seatbelts and airbags
and made the road safer so it's that
type of approach that's gonna be
required in order for us to really see
some change and reduce injury all across
this country yeah it seems like the the
gun rights groups want to argue that you
getting involved not only in treatment
but also prevention is like a special
pleading that in this one case doctors
want to get involved in prevention but
not in others it actually seems like the
special pleading would be asking doctors
to ignore the prevention piece when it
comes to gun gun violence when with all
other types of disease and public health
issues doctors are the ones that are
right in there working on that out angle
yeah that's correct I mean imagine if a
patient got brought into my trauma Bay
today and I decided I was not going to
treat that person right now it's just
completely unacceptable the same way
that it's unacceptable that we don't
work together from an injury prevention
perspective and look the reality is is
that when you look at organizations for
example the American College of Surgeons
they actually reached out to the NRA in
2017 to figure out how can we
collaborate and work together in order
to reduce firemen during death so you
know that second part of their statement
where we essentially consulted no one is
categorically false and again goes to
spreading this false narrative and I
think a lot of the leadership wants out
there I'd love to talk a little bit
about the research angle there is
something called the Dickey amendment
from 1996 which prevents federally
funded research from supporting gun
control or gun safety measures can you
talk a little bit about the ways that
doctors can get around that aside from
just sticking to private studies like
are there ways to circumvent that to
keep doing good work on this issue yeah
so what we've what we've seen over the
past 20 years essentially is you know
this you know end to really federally
funding
gun bans research and when you look at
the burden of disease that exists it's
just tremendous and it's nowhere near
funded at the level that is required so
right now we're starting to see a couple
things a lot of different private public
partnerships you know for example the
Laura and John normal Arnold Foundation
have committed you know twenty million
dollars with the plan to raise thirty
more million for gun violence research
we saw Blake mikowski who committed five
million dollars towards gun violence
research people are not willing to just
sit on the sidelines and wait for you
know essentially the government to take
action on this I I think the other
important piece is we're also seeing a
lot of great work being done by the gun
violence prevention community so you
know you take a look at the Brady
Campaign which in full disclosure I'm on
the board but they have a great campaign
on n family fire which is really geared
toward safe storage and you look at you
know what Giffords put out today with
encouraging Congress to fund the CDC so
there's a lot of stuff that's going on
and a lot of it is happening in parallel
but we have to think about those private
public partnerships as well what are the
biggest roadblocks right now to getting
anything done because I and my audience
a lot of my audience share this sort of
desperate skepticism that I mean if even
after Sandy Hook close to ninety percent
agreement in the u.s. that every firearm
transaction should come with a
background check universal background
checks and President Obama in in the
White House and seemingly almost every
factor in the right position still
universal background checks could not be
passed
so do you share that skepticism and what
what are the roadblocks other than just
politics well look is it is it
frustrating absolutely but I think it's
also David important to remember that in
this country most governing actually
happens at the local level and so when
you look at communities all across this
country there's a lot of different
you know pieces of legislation that's
been passed and so I say that only to
mention to you know all of your viewers
and Americans all across this country is
that each and every one of us have a
role and responsibility to play in
trying to make our community safer and
that starts within our own communities
but then also has a parallel kind of
effort at the federal level interesting
so so in so I think that that actually
is important because I don't think a lot
of people consider gun safety
regulations local issues beyond just
ordinances allowing businesses to say we
don't allow firearms here but so you're
suggesting that an approach would be to
try to tackle some of these issues
would it be at the municipal level at
the state level well I think it's both
and we start to see it Pittsburgh just
passed recently some some firearm
legislation you know we see different
states with you know some relatively
strict legislation that exists and a lot
of this has happened honestly because
there's been significant grassroots
movements when you look at you know
groups like you know moms demand and a
variety of other you know gun violence
prevention organizations like Brady and
Giffords they're all working at the
state level in the community level in
addition to the federal stuff and
sometimes that doesn't get highlighted
but it's also David one of the reasons
that voter turnout rate in our country
is so low because most people don't feel
like they can make a difference yes I
think we have to change that that
culture and that thought process
absolutely and that that can sometimes
be an uphill battles as I've experienced
we've been speaking with dr. Joseph
saccharin clinician researcher at the
johns hopkins hospital also founder of
the this is our lane social media
movement thank you so much for talking
to me today thank you so much have a
great day